[Musique]
et
bonjour tonton doit aller c'est ma
tournée
[Musique]
pendant ce temps à la maison on attend
ton doigt pour se mettre à table
oh là là l'europe qui va brûler
[Musique]
bravo tentons soit
m
c'est trop tard le rôti brûlé bravo à
tous les deux
[Musique]
fredo chats n'aiment pas devin
ah bah vous êtes dans un drôle d'état
[Musique]
bien entendu durant la nuit les deux oil
coliques sont malades et c'est encore
maman soit qui s'occupe de faire venir
le médecin
[Musique]
on les monte
on
non moi
les petits bateaux à tous pénètre dans
le café attrape les bouteilles bouteille
de vin bien sûr et les vides dans le
caniveau
ils remplissent d'eau et de sirop de
grenadine un autre côté la maladie de
pas pas où et quand ont voit ne
s'arrange pas wara qu'ils ont des
hallucinations
l'écoutille watts ou en profite pour
pénétrer dans l'appartement et là ils
répètent la même opération
le lendemain qu au café mais cette fois
sans entendons soit qu'est-ce que tu es
mon frère trop 15 mois au est ce que tu
crois que c'est comme ça que tu va
guérir credo chien boit du vin mais non
souvenez vous c'était de la grenadine at
war est un boni à watou à tous il n'y a
qu'un seul remède la piqûre
et après ça vous vous sentirez mieux
regarder
[Musique]
et attention hein maintenant il ne faut
plus boire d'alcool
[Musique]
les hallucinations port mais non vous
êtes presque guérie
oui mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo à toi tout
au revoir et merci
[Musique]
oh